well this talk is is mostly about mostly
about the pandas project or but about
Python Python data wrangling in general
and I gather that some of the people in
the room do a little bit of of data
wrangling I I now work for two sigma I
moved to New York just a couple of
months ago under the radar and so you
know mandatory disclaimer I so most
people know me as having worked on
worked on pandas which is getting to be
almost a ten-year old project had its
eighth birthday earlier this year this
year it's been open source for the
majority of majority of that time but it
did start as a closed source project in
in finance last couple of years I've got
involved in the apache software eaqubs
ecosystem and now very involved in the
apache arrow and apache park' projects
and working on on analysis tools at here
in new york at 2 Sigma about the last
couple of years at Cloudera working on
figuring out how to bring the Python
ecosystem and the Hadoop and spark
ecosystems together which has turned out
to be quite a rabbit hole of
infrastructure problems that need they
need solving and I'll touch on those
briefly if you want to hear about some
of those in much more gory detail you
should definitely go to Julian Liddell's
talk later this afternoon about about
Apache arrow I started another project
they are called called ibis which is an
attempt to bring a deferred expression
system that looks and feels like pandas
but can interact with sequel systems
especially sequel on hadoop but you
could also make it run on spark or many
different you know many different
backends so that's also an interesting
project you can check out
I am working on a second addition to my
book so if you own how many people own
the first edition
I have several copies so the goal of the
second edition given that the ecosystem
is settled down a little bit so we can
I'm comfortable writing about certain
topics which I wasn't comfortable
writing about in 2012 things like stats
models I could learn which were brand
new projects back then pandas was also a
brand new project in 2011-2012 but I
used the book as a tool to help me
finish the project so I would come to an
empty section in the book and say well
I've got to finish the code so that I
can write about it but things have
changed a lot the last five years and
I'm sure sure many of you are well aware
well aware of that
so five years ago Python had become
accepted as a scientific competing
language the community was really
focused on how do we get people to move
from MATLAB to Python that that was the
real consuming like he went to scifi
anything related to numpy sai PI the
numerical analysis stack and python it
was all about how can we you know get
into the traditional academic oriented
sign of computing ecosystems and that
was you know things like you know things
like MATLAB but now you know data
science has become has become a thing
and Python has become you know a primary
language for data science and it was
really great to see companies like
Google choosing-choosing Python as the
language to make their next-generation
deep learning framework available to
normal to normal humans so that's a big
milestone for the big milestone for the
for the community and the fact that we
have lots of conferences and places
where you can go and meet other Python
programmers also go to learn about how
to use these tools
you know site by conference has been
around for a long time but now we have
you know PI data conferences and there's
Python tutorials that's all the strata
conferences so there's there's many
places you can go and and be a part of
the community
so the community grew for a number of
reasons it didn't you know pandas
certainly helped because data is very
messy and we all have to clean up data
so if you don't have good data
manipulation data cleaning tools then
all of the rest of the things that you
want to do become very difficult so it
was certainly an important part of the
equation but we needed all these other
things we needed packaging we need to be
able to reliably install the same
packages that you have on your machine
on your colleagues machine
so having anaconda having better you
know binary wheels with pip you know may
have made a big difference
Jupiter notebooks have obviously been
huge scikit-learn has been huge and all
of it has been made possible by the
foundation of numerical computing and
numpy inside pi
another very exciting thing that's
happening right now is a project called
Conda Forge which if you're not aware of
I will make you aware of it but is it is
a community lead initiative to build
Conda packages so if you have a library
that you want to make available to
python programmers all around the world
they provide a hosted build
infrastructure where you can put up your
condom package recipe and it will get
built on an automated basis and deployed
so that anyone can Conda install Conda
install your package and they've dealt
with some of the really unpleasant
things like how do I ship this library
even though I'm running Ubuntu 1604
which has two new G Lib C and two new
live STD C++ and so there they set up a
compiler tool chain so that you can
deploy on many different Linux
distributions without running into weird
ABI conflict issues and so if you've
done a lot of C or C++ development this
is what you end up spending a lot of
your time dealing with so they've
they've solved that problem so so Bravo
it's it's really fantastic another thing
that I've been carrying a lot more about
as I've been doing open source for a
longer amount of time is how do we fund
open source because we all depend on
open source heavily and I'm sure that
you and your companies where would you
be without all these open source
projects
but it's very hard to collect money to
fund their development so you know
people like me I know have chosen to
work for companies specifically where I
have the opportunity to do open source
development so I was like I chose to be
a cloud era because that was a place
where I could do open source development
now being a to Sigma to Sigma is a place
where I can continue to do open source
development that's not always an option
for everyone and it would be great if we
had better funding avenues to collect
collect funds and enable people to work
full time building these projects that
everyone relies on so numb focus is one
organization which was created
originated in the Python community but
provides a way for companies to give
money to open source projects where it
goes into a not-for-profit organization
and then the the owners of those
projects can decide how to distribute
the money whether it's to freelancers or
or whatever so if you have if you have
spare spare cash and would like to fund
projects I encourage you to to look at
num focus as one one possible way to
support the projects that you that you
depend on every day so most of this talk
is about the Panda panda's project
itself and I will try not to put you to
sleep with extreme technical detail but
just reflecting on the project the
project structure where we are where we
came from we just released a few weeks
ago the 0.19 release and it's funny
because the project is depended on by
hundreds of thousands of people around
the world that it's still not a 1.0
release that we're in this eternal
eternal beta mode but the big the
biggest thing that's happened the last
four or five years is the contributor
basis has exploded so if you watch the
project I'd get on github there's an
extraordinary amount of activity we've
had over 5,000 pull requests and that's
all since we joined github in 2010 so
that's seen a multiple pole requests per
day every day for six years which is
crazy the amount of you know issues that
have been created a lot of those are
feature requests many are
documentation bug fixes some of the you
know the number of poll requests and the
number of issues are also because the
pandas project has grown into this sort
of super library that's trying to solve
every problem under the Sun related to
data manipulation and that's good
because you have something that's you
know full stack you know you get it's a
one-stop shop for solving lots of
different problems but it also makes for
huge amounts of edge cases and different
you know little bugs that creep up and
the fact that there's only 11 developers
who have more than 100 commits on the
project will show you that a lot of the
contributions are coming from real users
of the of the project who are just using
pandas to get their job done and they
run into a bug and they fix it and and
then that becomes they become a
contributor to the project so if you
look at the Google Analytics just for
the pandas website it's been you know
steady up in to the right the last last
five years I don't really know how big
the the user base is but you know we
have maybe seventy thousand unique
visitors to the to the website every
month so you know I it's probably
somewhere in the low hundreds of
thousands of users worldwide there are
certain lessons you can learn if you're
working on another open source project
about how to make open source project
successful I would say one of the
biggest reasons that pandas has grown so
big and become so successful is because
the contributors are extremely active so
if you're run into a bug you write a
patch worst thing that can happen when
you want to be involved in an open
source project is you submit a pull
request on github and then it sits there
and so it's crickets chirping for a week
or two and you Kuster the contributors
and maybe they maybe they review your
code but in many cases if you submit a
patch to pandas it would get reviewed
the same day feedback requested and you
could have less than 24 hour turnaround
time to get a patch merged into the
project
of course the library has lots of other
benefits you know the fact that it's
performance is good that it's one of the
only data preparation data cleaning
tools in python available since you have
dirty data you want to program in Python
so panda
is the tool that you use that that has
helped attract a lot of people to the
project and the fact that it's been used
continuously in production over its
entire lifetime I think we first used
pandas in a production use case in May
2008 and so you know it was probably a
bit premature given given the primordial
state of the library at that time but
you know we we survived so with an
8-year old project and you know over
200,000 lines of code and hundreds of
contributors and hundreds of thousands
of users the risk is that you get into
this paralysis mode where you can't
change anything because it will upset
too many people but yet you have
technical debt because there were
architectural decisions that you made
early on which made sense then and maybe
don't make sense now or you know about
new use cases which you didn't know
about five or six years ago that are now
you know popular use cases for the
project we didn't really think about
people using pandas for database ETL and
so maybe maybe many people in youth in
the room use pandas for ETL and that was
not something that we thought a lot
about another interesting trend is that
pandas is being used as a component in
larger systems so people are using PI
spark as a way to orchestrate small
pandas jobs so you know run this map
function which uses pandas to transform
some data and then run this reduce
function which uses pandas to combine
together to combine together datasets so
any problems that were related to that
distributed you know partition the data
set run all of these independent pandas
functions and then merge together the
results has brought up a number of
engineering challenges to make that more
flexible and more performant so one
concrete thing that we're going to do
which you should look out for is that we
are finally going to release pandas 1.0
which is probably long overdue it won't
be majorly different we're not going to
break a bunch of things but we are you
know looking at you know what are the
asked API changes we want to make before
we say that the library's API stable
let's focus on stability let's just fix
bugs make the library faster make the
documentation better and stop stop
changing arguments or breaking breaking
API s and if you go over the last
several years of the project we've
broken a lot of api's but almost all of
them have been good breaks and so if you
look at any API change in isolation you
can say oh I make sense why you change
this but if you're upgrading from you
know through sometimes people will wait
three or four major versions of pandas
to upgrade and all the sudden you're
dealing with a cumulative set of 100 API
changes and you haven't written enough
unit tests and so you have a really
difficult time upgrading your code base
so we would like to stop that stop that
pain for a while so that we can take a
step back and and look at the technical
debt that is accumulated in the project
so if you use if you use pandas heavily
especially for ETL maybe some of these
some of these problems are well known to
you you can't have missing data and
integers and boolean columns so it's not
uncommon to read data from a database
and find that the data types have
changed and they've changed without
telling you and that's that's not very
nice because when you go to write the
data back to the database you've got to
say oh well this column was originally
an integer but now it's a float with
Nan's and so you've got to have a bunch
of ad-hoc massaging code to to fix the
the schema of the implicit schema of the
data frame before you write the data
back into into the database and so
that's something that we would really
like to fix another issue which has you
know as the data has gotten bigger and I
think we can all agree the data sets six
or seven years ago we're a lot smaller
than they are now and this is a
fantastic tool if you have 100 megabytes
of data or a gigabyte of data but if you
have ten gigabytes of data 20 gigabytes
of data you start to you know spend a
lot more time worrying about well is
this line of code that I write going to
cause the memory to double
and there are a lot of places in pandas
where you can accidentally cause memory
doubling and so that's not great there
are certain places where there's
unavoidable unavoidable data copying
because of pandas relationship with
numpy numpy allows you to mutate mutate
any array I mean there is a flag you can
set to to disallow mutation but it's
fairly easy to accidentally mutate
another data frames data like if you
slice a chunk out of the middle you
change that chunk it's reflected in the
parent and that causes very unintuitive
behavior if you're writing a big group
by you mutate the chunk of data inside
the group by and you find the original
data set has been destroyed and that's
that's a very common stumbling block for
for users of the project so that's one
thing that we can fix it won't be easy
one of one solution to it is to make all
views and pandas copy-on-write so if you
obtain a view on a data frame it will be
zero copy so it won't copy any memory
but if you mutate that view at that
point it will copy it will copy the
memory so that the parent that the
parents memory is protected and vice
versa so if you have a child which has
sliced you let's say you load a giant
CSV file and you slice out a portion and
the you want to you mutate the parent
and some other code you don't want the
child's data to be to be mutated so the
copy-on-write goes both goes both ways
another issue for performance and you
know with our friend Moore's Law the CPU
cores aren't getting any faster anymore
there's just more of them and
unfortunately a lot of pandas is very
single-threaded some of the some of the
some of the single threading is hard to
hard to deal with because it's also
connects tup with the Python global
interpreter lock so whenever you're
working with strings in pandas and you
want to access the data that's inside a
string object you have to acquire the
Gil so this is a problem if you have a
large amount of text data string data
and you want to process it in parallel
because those threads have to acquire
the Gil every time they either create a
string or they want to access the
internal internals of that string data
structure so you know certain things we
can do there like moving all of the all
of the data in pandas for common types
like strings I don't know we don't
really use the term off heap in Python
but you can think of it as moving all
the data outside of Python objects into
a you know an area of memory where we
don't have to deal with the Python
global interpreter lock is one way one
way around that so the last big thing is
if your spark user your add ask user
we'd like to make pandas work a lot
better with those systems a lot faster
serialization moving data around and
tools to make these more distributed
MapReduce type type algorithms easier to
write using pandas as a as a building
block so the summary of all this is that
for the last year or so since last
summer December we've been discussing a
project we're now calling pandas 2.0
which is a significant we are connecting
of the internals of the pandas project
and the hope for a pandas 2.0 is that
you as a user won't know about it
you'll need to learn some new semantics
around if you have code which assumes
that you can slice a data frame and
modify it and it will be reflected in
the parent so things like you know
modifying views the semantics there will
change because of you know the issues
that I've just talked about but for most
pandas users they'll just continue to
use the library as they have their code
won't have to change so hopefully we can
get to you know 95% backwards
compatibility 98% backwards
compatibility but we won't be able to
have 100% backwards compatibility
because some things do need to change
things like missing data we like we want
to have missing data in integer columns
or boolean columns and you can think of
that as an API change and that will
cause backwards and compatibilities but
these are just things that we need if we
want pandas to be a serious tool for
data engineering
can obviously make the performance a lot
better some of that will come through
come through multi-threading you know
more careful memory management on but
over time you know with these multi big
multi-core machines with lots of RAM we
need to be able to fully utilize the
hardware that we have rather than
assuming that everything is everything
is single threaded and that we don't
have very large data sets so I don't
know if anyone is a C++ programmer in
the room but one of the the big
components of the project and if you
look at how panas is implemented
internally so in 2008 when I started
building the project panas was all
Python so there was no C there was no C
extensions anything like that it was all
Python and your you know and that was
fine for a while it was fine for several
months until start profiling and you
find a few hotspots and say okay I'm
going to write a few C extensions to
make those hotspots faster so fast
forward eight years later and now we've
got an extremely large pure Python core
business logic of how series works how
data frame works and hundreds of C
extensions and it's all been organically
driven grown incrementally without a lot
of thought about like a more like a
bigger like system architecture a lot
most of the C extensions are not very
interrelated either so a big part of the
project will be refactoring from from
this structure of a big Python core pure
Python core which is relatively slow
into a very tight C++ core which we're
going to call Lib pandas and that will
be wrapped in Python and we'll have that
will be you know where the user
interface that you see you see lives so
I'm not going to go too far down in the
weeds but if you're really interested we
can talk about about some more of you
know some of the benefits of the the new
architecture if you want to get involved
in the project but this will give us a
lot more flexibility to handle some of
these memory management and low-level
data representation issues things like
missing data it will also make some of
the cheap
operations and pandas like selecting
elements selecting columns you might
have noticed that some of these indexing
operations over time have gotten slower
so we want to make those a lot faster
again so if something can take less than
a microsecond let's let it take less
than a microsecond another thing that is
a big deal for working with really large
data sets and has been a long long
standing issue is that if you have data
on disk
there's no way to well there's almost no
way it's a memory map that data and make
it look like a data frame so you have to
completely you have to completely load
the data into memory and so there's a
linear cost to making data available to
pandas based on the size of the data set
so if you have 10 gigs of data you've
got to load all 10 gigs in a memory 50
gigs same deal
give a very large data set maybe it's
got a thousand columns it's 100
gigabytes but you only need 10 or 20 of
those columns you know it's hard to say
you know only load those those 20
columns depending on how you stored the
data so we'd like to make that and lazy
loading of columns as you need them a
lot easier it's been a lot of work with
file formats so so there's a lot of work
that we can we can look out there or at
least planning to integrate with some of
these on disk file formats and this
aspect will be critical to making pandas
a lot faster as a tool that's used with
distributed applications like spark like
spark and ask so that a you know spark
worker or a desk worker can receive a
payload of data can memory map that
rather than having to go through an
expensive deserialization process to
produce pandas dataframe
so all of this is very closely related
to a project that I've been a part of
for the last year or so called Apache
arrow which we just released as a new
open-source project
I'm not gonna go much in the detail you
can learn more about arrow from julienne
later but this gives us in memory data
structures for tabular data so not
unlike not unlike pandas and a protocol
for moving data around between processes
with minimal overhead and so you can
think about you know the arrow problem
of you know I want to move data from
point A to point B ordinarily you'd have
to write a custom adapter between two
sources and in the new world you know
using arrow we can have a single you
know interchange format that is very
efficient to read and write and
hopefully the pandas can you know memory
map without having to do a lot of D
serialization work so a couple of places
where we're already using this that I've
been involved in so earlier this year I
worked with Hadley Wickham in the art
community to create a project called
feather which is a file format for
storing data frame so you can write a
data frame from Python and read it in R
and it operates at roughly disk speed so
if you have as fast SSD in your hard
drive it's not uncommon to be able to
read and write and this data frames that
you know one to two gigabytes per second
which is which is pretty good you still
have the problem of having to load all
the data into memory which will take
some time to solve but that's very nice
we're also working on adding native
park' support to Python so we all year
we've been building a brand-new you know
from the ground up C++ implementation of
Apache park' and the target data
structure for data coming from Parque is
arrow arrays which can then be marshaled
back and forth the pandas dataframes
and that's very fast as well so just to
give you an idea of the benefits of fast
serialization and the impact that it can
have on your analysis I did some
back-of-the-envelope benchmarking one
gigabyte pandas dataframe
hundred columns I looked at a bunch of
common serialization formats and be
truly rigorous I need to publish the
code for the benchmarks that you can run
them run them yourself I didn't end up
adding everything everything to this
benchmark but so basically I used the
arrow has a inter-process communication
format right so we're calling a file
format but it's not really a file format
pandas has a interface to hdf5 called
HGF store which you may be familiar with
you can also pickle pandas dataframes
there's another library Python specific
library called B calls which is an
another columnar file format which you
can read and write from Python and these
are all RAM - Ram conversions so I
wanted to eliminate the the conflating
factor of disk performance or network
i/o performance so this is just data and
memory converting to converting to a
panda's data frame and so it's very
promising that you know we can get in
memory bandwidth between one data
structure representation another and
another it's over six cubed but you get
gigabytes per second but something I'll
porn at point out about these benchmarks
is that in the case of in the case of
arrow this 115 milliseconds is entirely
in the pandas dataframe constructor
because it insists on making a copy of
all the data that you're passing it so
in a world where everything is zero copy
you can receive a blob of data and
memory map it without having to go
through an extra copy step this time
effectively goes to zero so you know you
can think of it as you know being almost
infinity times faster so so that will be
very nice and I see that happening in
the future it's just a matter of writing
code famous last words right but just I
mean to put it in context comparing with
another common serialization format like
CSV files we shouldn't complain too much
because you know parsing CSV files can
also can be quite slow and even though
pandas read CSV is fairly fast you know
you're still looking at maybe
I can do mental math you know 42 you
know 42 100 something times slower to
deal in to deal in CSV files so a friend
of mine Damian EADS wrote a library
called paratext which uses
multi-threading and a lot of you know
C++ metaprogramming magic to get CSV
parsing up into the the bandwidth of
these other serialization formats but
they're you're really trading a lot of
CPU time for CPU cycles to get
performance out of CSV files but
sometimes you have data and CSV and so
you need to parse it as fast as possible
but if you think about these file
formats a lot of the file formats that
we use in Python are proprietary so
pickle is a proprietary format be calls
is is proprietary there's some other
proprietary formats that you can use and
there's a lot of benefits to using a
data format that is not Python specific
and that other systems can read
especially systems in the Java ecosystem
which traditionally have had a really
difficult time interacting with Python
you may have to you may have to interact
with the JVM through shared memory go
through sockets for some other means you
can do j'ni that is very painful but you
can do it but but that's a very exciting
you know possibility to bring you know a
lot tighter a lot faster memory
bandwidth between the Java ecosystem
especially SPARC and the Python kind of
you know pandas scikit-learn an
ecosystem you can also do things like
you know it's a common data format and
you can you know pick out a column or
pick out a set of columns so you can
start to think about predicates push
down and filtering filtering on disk
without having to first load the whole
data set into memory and then filter it
so that can also give you a lot better
performance in certain applications we
haven't planned you know adding indexing
on top of some of these formats but
that's something you could do to also
improve improve i/o performance but for
the Python community
because there's a very small number of
us writing code to be able to benefit
from the development efforts of other
language communities means that you know
they will do some of the work that we
don't have to and so kind of the rising
tide lifts lifts all boats and that's a
so that would be very nice if that if
that ends up happening so I thirty
thirty minutes went by very quickly but
thanks to the data engine comp
organizers for for having me here and
and of course you know none of this
would be possible without you know my
collaborators in the pandas community
the you know core developers and my
collaborators in the and ASF ecosystem
so thanks for listening and we have like
what five minutes for questions maybe
are there any questions
nope okay there uh so just just brains
are full Oh actually Oh hold up back
here I'm just going back a few slides to
you know we're talking about the the big
new features for pandas - yeah this one
or this one maybe one is what one back
I'll just blurt it out so as you add
these bigger bigger me your futures like
support for external engines and more
formats like just what what what
separates pandas from being a database
engine at that point like then you're in
your head like what is the key
difference and then what it is well
database engines are I mean if you have
to define what is a database engine so
there's a can of worms like do you have
you know do you have transactions you
know do you have like consistency you
know cuz you guarantees
I mean pandas has been has always been
an in-memory single node analytical tool
and I don't think we intend to to go
beyond that obviously single nodes have
gotten bigger they have more cores and
more and more RAM and so our goals with
pandas 2.0 or to better utilize you know
the hardware that's available on single
nodes and to leave the distributed
computing problems to other to other
systems but the let pandas plug into
those systems with less overhead but as
a database or a sequel engine or you
know using pandas instead of like you
know Postgres or some other kind of
sequel system I mean we don't we have no
plans for that
I mean possibly possibly I mean you have
systems like you know systems like KTB
which you know they are technically are
technically databases so you could
imagine if you had a way to you know
append you know here's like a panda's
data set on disk and here's a way to
write you know write data to it you
could start to think about it think
about it like a database but it also
brings with it a lot of other
expectations like you write data to disk
you would like to be able to read that
data in the future so having like
backwards compatible file formats it's
it's kind of a rabbit hole that I'm not
sure that we we want to go down but I
mean you know in a way in memory
analytics databases are not so far apart
semantically so it will be interesting
to see how that how that does develop in
the future I have a slightly unrelated
question um why do you think it is it it
was a case that Python became the
language that the scientific computing
community decided to use as opposed to
you know let's say Java was you know
like would be an obvious choice yeah the
well yeah I think the biggest reason was
in the so the late 90s early 2000s there
were a lot of scientists and academics
who spent a long time taking all the all
the legacy Fortran you know C C++ like
computational libraries and building
building Python interfaces for them and
I think the JVM is big a struggle has
been has been numerical has been
numerical programming so you know things
like you know blast lapak you know mkl
you can get at these you can get at
these things through through j and i and
off heat memory but it's it's still even
now like it's an active area of
development and development and research
and so the fact that you know because of
like architectural like just development
challenges of doing numerics
you know linear algebra and like array
computing in Java I think it was just it
was there wasn't the activation energy
and in the late 90s in the Java you know
Java development community was you know
very much focused on building you know
enterprise enterprise applications not
doing sign of a computing also Python is
very nice to program in so I think you
know I think in a lot of these
individuals were driven were attracted
to Python out of laziness
so go I can get done with what with less
work all you have all we have to do is
build nice user interfaces to the
computational libraries and so Python
became a scripting layer for Fortran
libraries and C and C++ libraries and so
kind of the orchestration layer for the
for the high-performance code and that's
still the you know still the way that
that you know Google and and you know
this I could learn and this way everyone
is approaching the problem it's kind of
the you know iceberg model if you know
you see the tip of ice poking out of the
water and but there's really there's a
big machine under the under the
underneath that you that's unseen that's
all the computational libraries which
are yeah yeah decades of development do
you think this is going to continue or
is a pendous three going to be in Julia
yeah I mean we you know we can I pant we
could have pandas and multiple languages
will just will create a brand you know
sure yeah